good evening ladies and gentlemen um
officers and members
i think i hope to also say good evening
to our cadets up there
um when i arrived this evening i i won
where the boat was but um just a little
bit of a pun but welcome
uh as always there's a little bit of
housekeeping i must read out to you
if the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the offices via the stairs
either through the security door which
is
the one
on my right
and also through the corridor to the
stairs
do not use the lifts
please assemble in hawley square on the
green officers will assist you and
advise you when it is safe to come back
into the chamber
um is there any person going to film
this
planning meeting tonight
could i please show
i don't think so and just remind members
that we are being live streamed on uh
sonic council's youtube channel
would
would any february prison please ensure
that the mobile phones are turned to
silent
and they are not used to make receive
phone calls in chamber whilst the
meeting is in progress
are there any members who
are going to speak who aren't on the
committee
uh speaking under 20.1
no thank you very much
public speaking uh the public following
applications have been reserved for
public speaking with members please make
a note
item 4b
upton county primary school legend
roadblock says
item
c
boat park east cliff promenade
broadstairs
and item for d
seagulls cliff promenade brawl says
on that point i'm going to hand over to
the planet applications manager mr
liverson
thank you chair good evening members um
a point of information for members on uh
gender item 4b this evening which is the
upton school application
on the plan condition which is number
two a couple of errors have been
identified
one is that the condition is drafted
refers to a plan ending one zero four
when there is no plan under
consideration with that reference so
this plan is removed from the
recommended condition
in addition
plan 303 revision a identifies the
proposed color of the building in
question as cream but the annotation
refers to an incorrect rail number
and this has also been updated in the
condition to confirm the cream color
proposed thank you chair
uh thank you
uh gender item one apologies for absence
i do have apologies from councillor
orban
and substituted by councillor alan curry
are there any other apologies
thank you agenda item 2 are there any
declarations of interest
thank you
agenda item three the minutes of the
planning committee held on the 18th of
august uh 2021
uh do members agree that the minutes of
the planning committee held on that date
be approved and signed by myself could i
have a proposal please
several hands going up council heart
and a second of please
counselor paul moore
do you all agree
thank you members
item 4 schedule of planning applications
and public speaking
uh once again we still haven't had a day
out yet but if there are any site visits
it will be on or they will be held on
the 1st of october which once again is a
friday
agenda item 4b the plan application for
approval which is upton county primary
school hm road in broad says
uh speaking in favor is mr pester is mr
pesto here
hey guys thank you sir
one more time is that funny
that's good timing that was good timing
mr president you have three minutes
thank you
let me just um
get my notes here
so
okay so
eating everyone i just want to
got some notes here just to mention on
the application so
this application is to replace an
existing sports ability for pupils
which is totally unfit for purpose with
a new
a new one intended primarily for their
use the school has received the grant of
government funds for this purpose
in accordance with government policy the
school will offer the sports hall
as an asset for use by the wider
community
when not in use for the school
this relatively small size
of the building and this is not a
full-size sports centre
means that it will only be suitable for
a range of activity involving limited
numbers
badminton keep fit groups yoga dance
class etc
counsellors will remember that an
application for this facility was
originally submitted in november and
planning mission was granted in march
unfortunately subsequent technical
surveys indicate at the site on the
school field
originally proposed for new sports silk
on the imprint of the existing building
contained a substantial amount of infill
this would have necessitated
substantially
more complex foundations than those
originally proposed
an additional cost of over 90 000 grant
funds are not available for additional
expenditure
nor does the school have the capacity to
finance this
this has necessitated placing the
building elsewhere on the school site
because of the need to avoid objection
from sport england about incursion to
playing field space
the options for this are limited and the
current application
places a new building closer to edge end
road than the previous one
this has understandably given rise to
concern from residents
the school has met the residents local
councils and the planning officer
and has agreed to take a number of steps
to ameliorate any impact on residents
just further note the location i was
taking into account
minimum distances away from trees
um to prevent further impact on the cost
of the project
that's no view from me thank you
uh thank you mr president uh raising
points of concern mr mcculloch
good evening thank you mr chairman and
thank you to mrs suffel who emailed me
yesterday
clearing up a number of points that i
was otherwise going to raise this
evening
when this application was submitted i
lodged objections based on the location
and the color
i've never objected to the idea of a
sports hall merely the details
we had a face-to-face meeting on the
14th of june between residents the
school
and mr pester
where a greater understanding of the
residents concerns was manifested and a
change of color
from recycling bin blue
to cream was agreed
there's a subsequent site visit by the
case officer led to a change in
orientation to one that we the residents
had previously suggested on the 14th of
july
14th of june and which we had formally
submitted to the planning department on
the 16th of june
following a reappraisal of the pitch
layout sport england withdrew their
objection
which in any event was based on an
incorrect assessment of the number of
football pitches on the site
so we've now reached an acceptable
compromise the one that residents had
proposed but which was rejected at the
14th of june meeting with the school
there are a number of small issues
outstanding
relating to the pedestrian gate on
broadstairs road and the car parking
including the noise
but these are not really planning issues
and therefore we'll be addressing them
directly with the school
at the broad stairs and peter's planning
meeting councillor moore was highly
critical of the lack of communication
between the school and residents
if there'd been consultation prior to
the lodging of the application
school might well have their sport tour
by now or at least it would be under
construction
many of the residents of this road are
professional people
many are retired but we number lawyers
construction engineers town planners
head teachers
journalists
and uh others
i've lost me track for a minute there we
go
anyway
i'm hoping now that uh following this
rather lengthy process that lessons have
been learnt
and that in future the school
understands that it's part of this
neighborhood with the same obligations
to his neighbors as i have to mine
school have got my email address and i'd
be happy to assist in the establishment
of proper communication channels between
us and them
and finally if i've got the time can i
thank councillor maeve saunders and
councillor ross binks for their guidance
and help throughout this whole process
thank you
thank you very much mr mcculloch um i've
now asked the planning officer to
outline this application
and could you turn your microphone off
please push the button thank you
thank you chairman um this is the
application site outlined in red so this
is a school um located here this is
edgen road on the right hand side here
and we have bullseye's road and to the
top of this slide
and this is an aerial view of the school
and so the existing sports hall is in
this location here with a swimming pool
building to the front here
this is um photos of the existing sports
hall
and inside
so you can see the the need for this
replacement and facility
this is the
sports pitch next to
the sports will build in so on the left
hand side this is a swimming pool
building with the sports hall behind it
so this is the location of the proposed
sports hall
and so just a few a few views of that so
again in this location here so you can
see there's currently a pitch here at
the moment so the proposal was to
relocate this pitch further um off to
the side here
and then again this is the location of
the pitch here this is the existing um
pedestrian link that runs through to
paul says road and this here is the
nearest neighbouring property to the
site
and then looking again back towards the
front of the site so edge end road runs
along here behind these trees this area
here is the footpath link and this area
here is the the location of the proposed
sports hall
and then again just from the rear
looking towards it so again the the
existing um swimming pool buildings on
the right here with the existing sports
wall behind it
and again there this is taken from edge
end road looking towards the site so at
the moment there's um parking to the
front and then there's a some tree um
screening behind it and then the
proposed sports hall will be behind
those
and again another view so there's
proposed sports pictures in this
location here behind the trees
and again another view here and then
this is just a view taking a different
time of year just showing that the fact
that there will be some visibility of
the sports hall but also showing how far
back the sports will be so be located
behind
this fence in here which is
the pedestrian link
so again this is showing here the
proposed um demolition which is of this
building here
this plan shows the previous approval so
this was the previous approval for the
sports hall so it was intended
originally to relocate um the building
on the or re-place the building on the
existing um sports hall site
um as mentioned it's not been possible
to do that due to ground conditions
which is why alternative locations has
been looked at
this is now the proposal so again this
was the previous location here and it's
now intended to move this sport hall
further over onto the site of the
existing sports pitch
so this plan the plan originally
submitted showed the building wider so
it was turned around so it's orientated
with the wider renovation facing edge
end road which also meant it was closer
to the existing neighboring properties
and there was also concern about its um
distance to the existing buildings um
and a lot of um space here so this is
the amended plan reorientated the
building so that it's an area narrower
elevation facing onto edge end road
creating a greater distance to the
neighbours
again this is the previous plan showing
the previous um sighting of the building
and then it
it was intended to replace the sports
pitch by moving it over slightly
the intention now is to move it over
quite a bit further but there's still um
space in order to achieve this
so following the amended plan there was
um a concern raised by sport england who
were concerned that it wasn't possible
to replace this pitch but then this plan
was submitted showing that there is
space in order to achieve that and then
sporting going to have removed their
objection
this was the existing site plan and this
is the proposed site plan
so this
the hall will
accommodate two um
two uh courts inside the sport building
and then this front smaller section will
be
the changing facilities and toilets and
to serve the sports hall
and this is the elevation facing the
road so because it's a narrower
elevation
um
amendments have also looked at the
materials so originally this was
the blue metal cladding for the whole
building so now it's
cream metal cladding and then you can
see here where there's darker shading
this is timber
cladding which will add a bit more
interest to that elevation and there's
also timber cladding on the smaller
elevation as well front in the road
this is the rear elevation
and the side elevation so you can see
there's high level windows in the
building it's intended that these will
be non-opening windows in order to
reduce any noise impact to the
neighbours
and again this is showing the layout so
showing that the two courts that you can
get inside um and then the changing
facilities at the front so this would be
available for community use
and then this is a
showing the design of the building so
again you can see the cream color now
and the timber clad into the front and
breaking up that large elevation
this is the existing street scene so the
school is on the left hand side here the
nobody property on the right hand side
here and the
building is going in this location here
so you can see it's quite a tall
building compared to the existing
school buildings but it's necessary for
the activities that they're looking to
serve within the building um but by
pushing it over through these amendments
it's closer to the existing buildings
and again the greater distance to the
neighbours and so there's um
as i said there's previously the
building a building on the site was
approved it's a community facility which
we would support
and through the amendments is now a
greater distance to the neighbours
there's now restrictive conditions as
well on the consent that limit noise um
it limits the hours of use of the
building so it can only be used up to 10
o'clock at night it limits the lighting
so lighting any lighting's turned off at
the same time
and so the impact on the neighbours is
now considered to be acceptable through
these amendments
and and in changing the colour and the
orientation of the building the impact
on the street scene is also considered
to be acceptable so it's recommended for
approval thank you chairman
uh thank you emma i i move the officers
that recommendation be adopted because
my chair please second
oh second matthew thank you council
carmen cook uh members
councilman joe bayford
thank you chair um
this application is the result of a very
very long process of consultation
amendments um in order to address
concerns of the public sports england
um and
the one thing everyone seems to agree
about is that they do want to have a
sports hall there
no sighting is perfect for everybody but
i do think that every effort has been
made to meet the demands
and concerns of of of the residents and
of sports england and
i shall certainly be supporting this
application i'd like to see it going
ahead as soon as possible
uh thank you
for uh are there any other members wish
to speak cancer or more
uh yes thank you chad
i'm pleased to see that both parties
have entered into
conversations about this as i
recommended previously and it's nice to
see that the colour scheme has been
looked at to make it more aesthetic for
the surrounding area especially with the
wood cladding
i the only query i have is was there any
recommendations for extra screening by
trees or replanting on this site
at any time and i know we mentioned it
at town council but i'm not sure if it
was part of the agreement with this
application picture
maybe count some
more um there's currently no um
condition for actual replanting but
there is a condition to do the
biodiversity so um condition six
um looks at um ecological enhancements
within the site which could actually
then include new tree plants in
um so it does actually say that we would
be looking for actually sorry it does
say details or three replacement trees
actually and there's species
location to be submitted as part of that
so yes we don't actually know the case
location at the moment but it will come
in through that condition
thank you
yes thank you for that um i'd just like
to point out to the representative of
the school that obviously there was a
new campaign next year the queen's green
canopy where they're looking to plant
new trees and
specialist trees and maybe they might
want to contact and take that into
consideration uh for further enhancement
of the area thank you
uh thank you councilmoor councilwing
uh yeah as an ex director of sport in a
large comprehensive in in the north i uh
welcomed the addition of a sports hall
but i also accept uh in in my previous
role that that there has to be a jupiter
position with with your neighbors and
the community and the school needs to
sit within the community
i'm glad compromises have been have come
to and that we now have a sports hall
that that sort of meets the needs and
concerns of everybody but i would urge
the school to continue its dialogue with
the residents because i know how
community use of a sponsor which i also
fully support
can impact on the local community so
it's important that the two parties keep
talking as this as this project moves
forward uh thank you councillor wing
are there any other members wish to
speak
okay members um
i'm going to put this recommendation
which is for approval
to yourselves for the vote those in
favor
those against
abstentions
thank you members that includes me that
is carried thank you very much indeed
uh gender item for
c
which is the planet application for
approval
at the boat park at eastcliff promenade
in brussels
speaking in favor of this application is
miss scott
you have three minutes miss scott
[Music]
good evening
i'm here as assistant beaver scout
leader with firsts and peters in sanet
sea scouts a role i've enjoyed for the
past 14 years
our group are a sea scout group with
around 120 members between the ages of 6
and 14 divided into beavers aged 6 to 8
cubs aged eight to ten and scouts aged
10 to 14.
we do not benefit from our own scout hut
and land and traditionally we meet at
the associated halls of saint peter's
church and pre-covered the use of a hall
instant george's school our scouts meet
on wednesday evenings otherwise more of
our group would have liked to have
attended this evening
we are a registered charity with our
leaders or volunteers scouting offers
improvement in children's confidence and
teamwork skills empathy towards one
another and learning new skills from a
wide range of activities that many
children would otherwise not experience
children of all faiths and abilities are
welcomed
we provide a range of water-based
activities and training under qualified
leaders in sailing canoeing and kayaking
along teaching general water safety and
survival skills skills that we hope you
will agree are essential when living by
the sea but also skills that can provide
much enjoyment throughout the children's
lives
our group is recognised by the royal
navy with group number rn55 and is
subject of inspections by the royal navy
to ensure standards in training are
maintained
a small number of our children have
chosen to join the royal navy and our
current group scout leader is a serving
member
our boats and safety equipment are key
to our ongoing success as a group and
the safe and suitable storage of these
items is essential
we have been very grateful that for some
30 years we've had use of land at emco
wheaton to store our equipment however
with the company now needing the land
alternative suitable storage is
essential
whilst many of us store general activity
equipment within our homes we are unable
to accommodate the storage needs of
boats and associated equipment including
the sunlight 60 plus life preservers
that all children must wear when they're
on the water
as regular users of the sea off viking
bay the proposed boat park will provide
an ideal location for the boats with
easy access to the beach the compound
will be located adjacent to that used by
broadstairs sailing club which is hidden
from view from the main beach area of
viking bay boats are very much expected
items to be found adjacent to the sea
and this location will not appear out of
place
with waiting lists to join we're a busy
group which is lucky to have the support
of many volunteer leaders who put time
and effort into the many activities and
boating opportunities we provide to a
large number of local children we very
much hope to continue this and ask for
your support in approving this
application thank you
uh thank you ms scott um i'll ask scale
planning officer um annabelle to outline
the report thank you
sorry thank you jeff
um this is the application site outlined
in red here the two red title
red rectangles you can see there are the
proposed containers
so this is an aerial view of the site
you can see rectory road here
the east cliff promenade running along
the seafront and this is a broad stairs
sailing um club site which also stores
boats and is enclosed in a similar way
to what is being proposed for the
application site here
so this is um
a zoomed in view
so this is the site roughly in this
location here and it would follow the
line
of the neighboring
sailing club so maintaining an access
way along the promenade
and so some just some photographs of the
site
as you can see it is screened from the
upper levels by the cliff
this is enough of you and you can just
see the fence on the left hand side of
the slide of the broadstairs sailing
club
and a third view where you can see
um as mentioned previously that it would
not put the proposed enclosure would not
protrude any further than the broad
stairs
club site now and members of the public
could freely walk up and down and
promenade as as as they can now
um
so
this plan shows post storage containers
there is a condition on the application
which looks for the precise color of the
containers to be submitted and agreed
with the local authority and on the
bottom left-hand corner that's the
details of the fencing that's proposed
and it's similar in nature's to what
you've seen on the broad stairs sailing
um
site adjoining the proposed application
site
it is um it is um in
the site is within a conservation area
sorry but it's not considered to be out
of keeping with the area and as has been
mentioned you would expect boats and
other facilities like that to be stored
within easy access of the seafront
there are the containers um could be
considered to be slightly out of keeping
but there is a container of a similar
nature on the broadstairs seining club
site and it is considered of appropriate
colours detailing of those containers
they would be acceptable so the officer
recommendation is for approval
uh thank you annabelle a movie officer's
recommendation is adopted because vice
chair please second oh second not you
thank you council common cook members
do anybody wish to speak
counsel exactly
thank you chair just a quick point on
the containers um
having seen the storms down there and
the damage that is caused down there um
after the autumn storms uh will these
containers be actually bolted down or
will they be pre-floating when the tide
comes in
[Music]
annabelle
i don't have the precise details i would
assume they would be fixed in some way
to avoid
any occurrence of that
i suggest uh suggest for councillors see
you come sit on them
yes thank you chad
um it's with regard to the colour scheme
um my concern is that obviously this is
a blank canvas for would-be graffiti
artists to keep damaging them
so would it not be um
a consideration that they blend in a bit
better maybe they're painted like beach
huts they look like like a row of beach
huts so they blend in we have them on
stone bay we have them on viking bay and
it just might blend in and deter people
from actually defeating them if they
look like beach huts it's just a my my
whim i'm just just putting it out there
thank you
i'll come to annabelle i know my
thoughts on that but um uh well they are
storage containers in the traditional
sense that are being proposed they're
not you know
they will not look like me chucks
physically but
um and the condition only relates to the
color to be agreed but there's no reason
why
a color could be put forward or a scheme
that could resemble some sort of beach
hut color
could be
promote put forward to us to look at
thank you the only reason i mentioned
that chair is that um in margate foreign
club they have iso containers down there
for their their launch vehicles and they
were run slightly after a while and tdc
open spaces have asked them to paint
them to blend in and they were looking
to do murals of beech huts across the
side so it blended in and looked more
aesthetic that's just a suggestion okay
i would also point out the site is going
to be fenced and gated in the similar
way to the broad stairs sailing club so
hopefully there won't be too many
opportunities for people to get in there
and
vandalize the containers thank you
annabelle uh cancer joel bayford
thank you chair uh yeah i think this
potential change of use would be hugely
beneficial to the sea scouts and
therefore to the local community and i
think it should be supported i i'm sure
that some
choice of colors will be sensitive
um and sensible
but i i have seen no reason not to
approve this application thank you
thank you councilman bayford uh do i see
any other members wish to speak
okay once again remember as i put this
to you those in favor
against
abstentions
that is carried and i just like to say
that uh do a wonderful job i think we
all agree
uh keep the good work up thank you
[Music]
i will now let you depart
[Music]
in order i should ask please and we
should get somebody out there with a
whistle
uh thank you thank you members um agenda
item 4d is the planning application
for deferral
of the seagull goals
cliff promenade in brooksville's
speaking in favor of the application mr
brown
this application has been the subject of
discussion with your planning officer
resulting in changes reducing the scheme
and addressing initial concerns relating
to issues such as ecology archaeology
the scale of the building and its
relationship with the area
my client thanks your officer for their
time and thought to address these issues
the application has been called to
committee for two reasons over
development and being out of keeping
with the street scene
these reasons are dismissed using quotes
from your officers report
over development implies the scheme
covers too much sight the building's too
close to boundaries and higher than
buildings around it however the officer
states and i quote
the building will be set in the rope
from the road by 15 meters by 5.4 meters
from the south boundary and 4.2 meter
from the north boundaries 3.2 meters
further away from the boundary than the
current dwelling
the building incorporates space to
either side of the site which maintains
a sense of space
the building would have a greater degree
of separation and not appear visually
dominant the height of the building will
be comparable with adjacent buildings
your officer quotes confirm the proposal
is not over development indeed the
separation to boundaries is much greater
than on adjacent plots
in terms of street scene the north
fallen estate has diverse forms of
buildings large square modernist blocks
are commonplace sitting cheap by jail
with mock georgian mansions and 1970s
shelley bungalows it is hard to imagine
a more diverse and less uniform
streetscape
that is the character of the area
again i would like to use quotes from
your officer to give the planning
department view of the screenscape
there are examples within north fallen a
three-story flat roof buildings the
design of properties varies considerably
the building's positioning within the
plot replicates the existing staggered
positioning evident on the existing form
of buildings
your officer makes it clear that the
design of the scheme and its sighting on
the plot are in accordance with the
existing character of the area
a scheme for eight flats in a
three-story flat roof building on a
similar site was allowed at red riff in
north fallen avenue with no objections
this scheme and other examples confirm
that such proposals are acceptable on
the north fallen estate
i would also remind members that their
policies acknowledge a higher
requirement for two-bedroom homes this
scheme provides a more balanced housing
provision in an area of predominantly
large detached houses it will also help
meet the present shortfall in housing
provision
thank you
thank you mr brown uh raising points of
concern miss libbington
ms levinson
good evening i speak on behalf of many
residents and organizations who objected
to this proposed development and i speak
against it on the following grounds
firstly it is out of keeping with the
character of the neighborhood
all existing properties on cliff
promenade were built as single dwellings
three have been converted to flats but
all using the original footprint and
structure
this proposal would mean demolition of
the existing house to build eight flats
and an underground car park in what is
most
what is currently mostly a garden area
it is not intended to develop the whole
of the current site for flats as a large
portion is being retained probably for a
further development at a later stage
which will create huge access problems
for neighbours in north fallen avenue
currently there are 20 houses along
cliff bromnard and four large empty
plots
if planning is granted for seagulls to
build flats the precedent will have been
set and the floodgates open for every
other plot to do likewise
come to the subject of highway safety
cliff romney is about half a mile long
about five meters wide bordered by cliff
on one side and grass verge on the other
parking along the road is discouraged
because it's part of the viking coastal
path and advertised by visit kent dot co
dot uk as one of the most attractive
circular leisure
routes in kent it is built as family
friendly for walking and cycling and is
part of the regional cycle network 15.
heavy traffic during construction and
subsequent increase in vehicles from
many more residents and their visitors
along with increased deliveries etc will
create many dangers to pedestrians and
cyclists in what is essentially a
country road
there would be inadequate parking
provision because within this
proposal there is an underground car
park
but seagulls is towards the narrowest
part of the cliff
and in a place a position where cliff
falls have already occurred
indeed
if we come to it the aerial photographs
submitted in the most recent planning
application
show recently fallen chalk on the beach
at the bottom of the cliff
the intention to build such a car park
could have an overwhelming and
irreversible impact on the structural
integrity and stability of the cliff
we must consider nature conservation as
well and the cliff top is a wildflower
meadow and one of the few places in the
uk where the very rare and protected
lizard orchid grows
also for some years now peregrine
forking falcons have been nested in the
clifftop
and these birds are protected by the
wildlife and countryside act of 1981
so large building works so close to
their habitat would be detrimental to
their continued existence
on all of these grounds i hope you will
see good reason to reject this
application it is not viable or
acceptable for the environment or the
neighborhood
and in no way will it produce any social
housing
uh thank you very much i will now ask
the plane officer which is annabelle to
outline the report
thank you chair
and this is the application site
outlined in red
we have wayfaring
and little wayfaring
to the
sorry to the right of
the slide adjoining the property the
application site and huckle to the left
with hardwick house beyond it
and this is cliff promenade to the
bottom of the side and then we have the
cliff
and the sea
so looking an aerial photograph
this is the application site outlined in
red
way fair and little wayfaring sorry
wayfaring a little wayfaring and huckle
to this side
and the area along here that you can see
is actually a designated roadside nature
reserve
so looking at some photographs of the
site
and the application site which is
seagulls is the white building you can
just see in the middle here this is
wayfaring a little wayfaring and this is
hucklow
um moving along the road a bit so we the
application site would be on the
left-hand side of the slide just off the
shot here and this is wayfaring and
little wayfaring and the houses as a
cliff promenade um carries on away now
so we have
seagulls the application site here
that is the roof of
um hucklow and that is wayfaring and
little wayfaring
and this is looking with the application
site on your right
and that this is hutclo and this is
hardwick
house
as you turn the corner there
so this is looking at from the front of
the application site so this is existing
seagulls building
and this is wayfaring on the right hand
side of the slide
sorry bear with me
um again this is an offer view of the
rear of
seagulls as it stands and this is um
wayfaring beyond
and that as you can see is a much
tighter relationship in terms of the
distance between the properties
and this is standing in the garden
of
seagulls and looking back to the rear of
it
and this is actually is
looking at the rear of seagulls and this
wall you can see here is actually the
edge of
wayfaring
as members will have noted and has been
mentioned tonight the application as it
has been significantly amended since its
original submission
this is actually the original submission
um here at the bottom
and this is the outline of seagulls as
it stands at the top the original
application proposed ten flats eight two
bedrooms and two free beds and as you
can see it essentially spanned the whole
width of the application site
and
was had little relief in visual terms
so this is the amended scheme this is
the front elevation to the top of the
site
and
as you can see it is much smaller it is
has been brought in from the edges of
the site so it doesn't
span the entire width of the plot
and it has a much
more comfortable relationship i would
say than even with the existing um
seagulls building and huckle
which sits to its right here
this is the rear of the building
and again members can see it is
staggered and as you go up in the
building the third floor is
set in from the sides and it has a much
more
interesting and
visual
um relief to it rather than the square
block that we saw in the initial
submission
um in terms of materials we are looking
at brickwork render
um and some vertical cladding wood
cladding which are materials that are
within the north fallen area
so it is considered they are acceptable
the existing building the seagulls
building has an overall height to the
top of its ridge 7.3 meters
and the height of this proposed building
would be 9.4
but this is not considered to be
incompatible with surrounding
development and there has been some
three-story buildings allowed in the
vacant plots that sit further along on
cliff promenade and indeed within north
fallen as a whole
so this is the proposed
layout so you can see the building here
the ramp to the parking and it might be
slightly difficult to see but you can
see the dotted line of seagulls itself
[Music]
so this is the underground car parking
that's being talked about and it has a
provision of 10 spaces to serve the
flats and there are eight flats in total
now being proposed
this is the ground floor plan and you
have three flats two
looking that way and one running the
length of the building to the rear
the first floor replicates that settings
are further three two bedroom flats
and the penthouse or second floor has
two larger units or larger units but
still two bedrooms
in that location
and this is the roof plan
so to conclude the proposed development
now would contribute eight dwellings to
the district's housing housing supply is
considered appropriate in terms of
design
and scale and provides a good level of
accommodation for future occupiers
there would be no adverse impacts on the
residential many many amenities of
surrounding occupiers highway safety or
parking
and concerns have been raised about
ecology particularly in relation to the
roadside nature reserve which has been
mentioned is directly opposite the site
cases ecology have been consulted and
they consider this matter can be dealt
with via condition
for construction management plan to be
submitted and agreed
and and then a monitoring survey
of particularly the nature reserve site
to see if there has been
any impact from the development
and if there is
um
means of remedying
that disturbance would have to be
submitted and agreed with us and a
timetable for that to be carried out
and there is the recommended requirement
for the undertaking to be submitted for
the sam contribution
and it is therefore recommended that
members defer and delegate the
application
for approval subject to the stakeholding
conditions set out in the report and the
appropriate and the receipt of the
appropriate undertaking
thank you
uh thank you very well a move the
officer's recommendation is adopted with
the vice chair please second or second
aren't you
thank you council cop cook um
members do you wish council heart
thank you chair been quite quiet this
evening for me so um i thought so that's
how i spoke um my concern is we have
eight flats i believe
all two or three bedroom now we're
assume
as well i know where this is really um
there's not much space really to go
shopping and to catch a bus to go to
school so everybody's going to drive
you've only got 10 places you should at
least have 16 because everybody's gonna
need a car probably two he goes to work
she takes the kids to school etc etc um
well either way it might be the other
way around that's you know um but i mean
i just
i have a slight concern that there isn't
enough provision for parking unless
there's going to be out some outside and
it is going to end up on the road which
in that area really is probably quite
unsightly um so i think that needs to be
addressed um i am slightly concerned
about um
privacy for the neighbours as well
especially as every the top flats can
probably look straight to their gardens
and the other houses don't have that
facility to do that themselves so that's
my only concerns with this thank you
thank you council heart
councilman
yes thank you chad this application was
brought before bruce's town council
council t planning committee and uh we
were against it so i will not be voting
for this application thank you
thank you accounts some more uh
councillor wing thank you chair uh can i
ask
is there going to be some uh excavation
in order to create the underground
parking area
yes there will be
so we all live on the chalk cliff and i
obviously obviously we have rock falls
we have cliff falls on an annual basis
how has there been any look as to how
that excavating that close to the cliff
could impact on possible cliff falls
not with this application it wasn't
considered necessary because it wasn't
on the actual cliff edge
to have a cliff stability or land
stability survey done
but that would be a matter for building
rigs it would obviously have to be
constructed in a manner that was
appropriate and safe
i would suggest that's quite risky
thank you councilwing council garner
thank you yeah i um
i have a couple of
concerns with this application
um
firstly a
minor-ish concern which was raised by
the kcc flood and water management
i see that the
applicant is proposing that surface
water runoff discharges into a
geocellular soakaway system
which kcc themselves say there's
insufficient info for that to assess the
feasibility of the proposal
and so that's one concern i have
i think a concern raised by councillor
wing
is my major concern i mean
this
is a little bit background
i went on a walk along that area this
week an organized
walk called the smugglers trail and we
were told about the um
cliff erosion especially around
king's gate botany bay
and it was mentioned that up to 15
centimeters
a year of cliff is eroded
so quite quickly that's that's going
and i'd really have a concern that the
construction
of this building and the underground car
park
is likely to
there is quite significant risk
of causing further damage to the cliff
face
um and i really would need
much more assurance that there wasn't
going to be any
that there wasn't going to be any of
that damage before i was able to in all
good conscience
support the proposal
um and another minor one that was raised
i know in the report that kent police
have said they cannot recommend the
approval
um and they've listed nine outstanding
points relating to designing our crime i
know that isn't a major thing but it's
still
something that i think should have been
dealt with before
before it came to us
thank you council ghana
and
annabelle
yes
mr limits and come back to you
thank you
just to pick up the point about
excavation the report talks about the
the distance in this instance from the
the cliff edge um and it's been
mentioned it's the the narrow one of the
narrower parts of the sort of cliff edge
to front and residential properties
along cliff promenade
um but the the sort of the process of
excavating will be subject again to
building rigs and i appreciate the
concern about the risk
in terms of um that excavation but
obviously it is subject to
national legislation to ensure it's done
in a safe manner in terms of the impact
on cliff falls um we consider the
distance is sufficient to not result in
that but there is obviously um again the
provision to make sure that the
excavation is carried out in accordance
with building regs and it can be that
distance um it's not considered to be a
significant issue to your point about
erosion though that is something that
again um the council's previously looked
at with regards to properties on the
sort of cliff edge we had a property in
peg well um which in fact went to um
appeal with regards to it and again even
though with the rate of erosion that
you've identified the test is usually
whether or not a development well it
certainly used to be would would last
100 years effectively if you build it
you know will it last sufficient uh
sufficient sort of time and again
because of the distance in this in this
instance away from the cliff is
considered that is not a major concern
that would um result in the need to
refuse the application because it's not
going to be sustainable development
because obviously it would have to be
you know it would it would disappear in
you know in 100 years um if i may just
pick up the
the point with regards to um
overlooking the councillor hart
mentioned um
you'll note that there is a condition
specifically related to obscure glazing
on the upper windows of the property on
either side to avoid overlooking so i
think you can see on the elevation on
one of the side elevations you've got
some of those upper windows so they are
um you know put forward to be obscure
glaze to try and avoid any overlooking
to lose privacy for for neighboring
properties thank you chair
thank you again sorry can i just come
back on certainly the points about
drainage that have been raised
you are quite correct councillor garner
that originally when the application was
submitted there was a detailed drainage
strategy which set out exactly
all the details of the drainage but as
you correctly say kcc's suds were not
satisfied with there was sufficient
detail within that that detailed
drainage scheme has now been
removed from the application there is a
condition requesting full details of
drainage to be submitted and approved in
the normal way so that is no longer an
issue
i think that and well
canceling
could i just come back to ian livingston
so the decision planning made on the
structural integrity of the clifftop was
that a decision made by planning alone
or was it a decision made in seeking
expert advice of people who understand
the structural integrity of of chalk
clear faces
um it it's it's a judgment made by
planning officers so no i i you know i
can't say that um specialist advice was
given with regards to cliff chalk faces
but in our opinion it's not necessary
and that's our professional opinion with
regards to the planning considerations
in this application
uh thank you and councillor joe baffert
thank you chair um
i'm afraid of
there are so many issues with this
development i also have serious concerns
about the stability of the cliff face
um the parking issues raised by
councillor heart i think are substantial
i think there could be a considerable
effect on the
biodiversity of these sites
i do believe that flats are out of
keeping maybe not over development but
out of keeping in this area
and as our speaker pointed out this will
result in no social housing and neither
will it result in any affordable housing
in my view
i i i don't feel i can support this
application at all thank you
thank you councillor bayford are there
any other speakers uh that's rusevski
[Music]
thank you chair um looking at the
um
original proposal the second proposal
the second proposal does look
a lot better
um
i think
looking at the different uh
buildings around north fallen i don't
see a problem with that building at all
um personally i think it's far enough
away from the clip
um having an underground parking system
i'm sure that if they needed more
parking they'd have enough room at the
top to put a couple of cars if they
needed it um personally i can't see any
problem with it and i will be supporting
it thank you uh thank you councillor
zesky yeah
sorry casa hopkinson
thanks chad um yeah just on the
excavation issued uh appreciate the
extra
bit of information on that but i do
still share some concerns about this uh
given that you know the judgment's made
in the absence of uh specialists
knowledge on that issue
um so i i'm still a bit concerned about
approving this without that specialist
thank you for that councillor hopkinson
any other speakers council clinton
i just wanted to double check what the
proposal is uh when i heard what i heard
you say
didn't tell you with what it says on the
top of the form which says defer and
delegate and was that what you said
and if so what is the delegate part
yep
um so as the
with this sort of development for
residential development there's a
requirement for a unilateral undertaking
to secure a financial contribution um
the recommendation is to defer and
delegate to officers uh for the risk to
await the receipt of that legal
agreement for that to be checked over by
legal and then we would approve the
development on the basis of the
conditions as outlined and the agreement
so it's deferred by members before
approval so members would be approving
it effectively but with just some
formality to deal with afterwards
okay thank you
i can't see any other members
so
once again members i'm putting this to
you
with the officer recommendation is to
defer
and delegate
those in favor
[Music]
against
abstentions
that motion has been lost
i turned to
mr livingston as usual thank you
thank you
um so
the main issue that's been raised is is
the concern regardless of the excavation
um and um the concern about potentially
the lack of a professional opinion with
regards to whether or not there is an
issue with the the cliff face
what is what we would recommend as
officers is
that
we do a sort of two-pronged approach so
it's it will be deferred back to
officers
uh to a combination of seeking further
information from the applicant if
possible but also seeking the opinion of
the technical services team of the
council who we would involve when
looking at structures much closer to the
cliff
but to get their advice with regards to
both erosion rates and also with regards
to potential issues with stability in
this area
and then we would report the application
back to members following receipt of
that information
for mems the planning committee to
consider
thank you and for that um
members
you understand um i'm going to need a
proposal if you don't mind
taking what you've heard mr livingston
if you agree to that
thank you councillor could i have a
second uh uh councillor crittenden uh
members are you in favor of what you've
been told there
yes
vote
okay sorry sorry keep your hands up
sorry
okay
as well against
abstentions
right that suggestion to come back to
committee
has uh been carried
thank you members
uh that concludes uh public speaking for
this meeting if there are any members
um
wish to speak i'm going to ask the clark
to read out the following applications
which are on your agenda
thank you so the final items on the
agenda is 4a which is for approval it's
the garden center at montefiore avenue
in ramsgate
and the second one is 4e which is for
deferral and delegation again
the old moorings in gronin bay avenue
birchington
thank you no okay
um
could i ask a proposal for what you've
heard there and then we will debate
um the garden center proposal please for
the one application that's not being
heard
how's the heart
a second and you will agree
agreed on me thank you thank you james
right
andrew to
submission
thank you
uh the application
is for uh the a new warehouse building
with a canopy at the brownsgate garden
center
which is located on hillson road the
site is outlined in red with the blue
line denoting the overall garden center
site
so this is an aerial view of the
application site you can see that
there's the large parking area
to the rear um for the garden center and
then there's the area to the bottom of
the image which has a lot of storage and
of ancillary
pallets
and
stock uh for the garden center
just looking at that in a bit more
detail so along the the bottom of the
the picture you can see muir road to the
right of the picture you've got
brindle grove and then hearson road is
on the left-hand side
so this is a photo showing the location
of where the warehouse would be so the
image is showing a view to the south
which is the back of the properties on
muir road
this is an image looking to the east
towards brennan grove um an important
point to note here is that there is a
land level change between the site of
the application to the properties on
brinwall grove it's between
0.8 and 1 meter higher the land level on
brindle grove and we'll see an image
from that
those properties looking back towards
this site
and then this is the view from the site
looking towards hearson road so you can
see various fenced off areas used to
store stock etc for the garden center
so we're going to look just for some
images from the different roads around
us so first starting with muir road
which is to the south so looking through
um if you can see where the mouse
pointer is hopefully that's showing up
um through those two sets of um of
terrace properties
um looking through to the site so you
can see there's a tree in the background
there so
the warehouse building would be
partially visible through the gaps
between properties on the road
and then looking from brindle grove
which is on the right hand side of the
image
um you can see here the two properties
where the the warehouse would sit behind
so this garage roof was the roof of the
the single story structure you could see
over the fence from the image where you
had the bin storage containers uh
previously
um so this is the proposed site plan um
and i'm just gonna go into a little more
detail to show you the warehouse so
this
has been subject to previous application
which was refused the application
was refused due to the size and scale of
the warehouse and what's then now been
proposed in this application has changed
the size to drop the height of the
proposed warehouse
and recite the canopy and the main
entrance to the warehouse the warehouse
is proposed to be used in connection
with the garden center so there is no
change of use of land and there is a
particular condition which is being
imposed which means that the warehouse
has to be used ancillary to the garden
center so and as you've seen that area
is currently being used as open storage
to move things as well as the you know
the bins uh for uh for the the
commercial unit
so um this is i'm just gonna go through
the elevations of the development so it
looks it looks like a like a warehouse
um you've got um grey goose wing gray as
the um
as the color for the unit so this is a
view to the south uh of the warehouse so
um we are supposed looking from the muir
road properties if you look on the right
hand side of the image you will see the
change in level that occurs to the
properties on brindle grove so there's
the level change here so they're
excavating the land to ensure to
maintain the land level um with the
canopy down you can see the existing
fence height
from which was you know the fence was
visible in those images shown earlier
uh this is the elevation facing into the
site um so to the to the west where the
main entrance is going to be
uh and then this is the view from the
the car park of the garden center so to
the north um of the site
um so this is the view that you would
see from brindle grove um so you can see
that the canopy
is um is the sort of middle line above
the fence side so this is the existing
fence with then the roof pitching away
uh from the site so if we look if i look
go back to this image you can see again
the level of canopy on the the left hand
side and the whole elevation then pitch
or the whole roof slope pitching away
from that boundary
and so this is the the view from the
east but obviously you can see the the
blue dotted line the bottom dotted line
that crosses the whole plan shows the
boundary fence line um so the roof would
be
visible but obviously pitching away from
the neighboring properties
so this is just the layout of the
warehouse it's obviously not not got a
lot of detail on it but it does show and
confirm the you know position of the
main entrance into that area uh with the
proposed canopy at the rear
and then
this is the roof plan which um includes
some solar panels which will be
installed on the
warehouse roof
so the main consideration has that we've
looked at is relation to the living
conditions as well as an impact on the
character appearance of the area due to
its location um sort of the back of the
garden center it's not considered that
the development in itself would be um
would affect or significantly impact on
the character and appearance of the area
um whilst there will be glimpsed views
they're not overly prominent and because
the land level changes and distance from
the roads around there it's not
considered to cause harm to the
character and appearance of the area the
impact on neighbours though is something
that has been looked at um throughout
this application to follow up from the
last proposal
and obviously the key issue is with
regards to the fact that the height has
been reduced from this proposal which is
the proposal that was refused and the
concern was due to exciting even though
there is a distance from the neighboring
properties um
of um it's
about 14 it's about 15 meters from the
rear of properties on brindle grove um
and it's
about 18 meters from the rear of
properties on muir road the the proposal
you can see in front of you was
considered to be harmful by virtue it's
its height as mentioned that has been
significantly reduced in this proposal
to try and alleviate the impact so it
doesn't appear dominant we do consider
that the reduction in height and the
distance in this instance is sufficient
to avoid an impact on outlook from those
residents
the other issue is with regards to
potential impact on noise and
disturbance so as mentioned the existing
use of the site is ancillary to the
garden center so it is used for open
storage at the moment and that does
obviously result in a noise impact um so
there's um you know there is a benefit
to some extent of actually containing
any movement of things or storage by
putting a warehouse in this location in
comparison to what is at the moment for
open storage but at the same time there
is a potential that you formalize the
area and you formalize the use by
putting a warehouse there
so what's been put forward um
which has been conditioned is a
restriction on the hours of use of that
um warehouse as well as deliveries and
you know back and forth from that
warehouse to basically start at 7 00 am
in the morning now it's worth noting
that at the moment there are no
restrictions on the time of the use of
the garden center because um
it was approved in the 70s
and and therefore you know we do think
on balance this um from this restriction
it has
it has led to improvement in in the
situation it certainly doesn't cause
harm to the residents following this um
some concerns have been raised and we
have received one additional comment
after the submission after the
publishing of the agenda which raises
issues to do with
uh noise as well as a light pollution
there is a condition that's proposed
that for any lighting if it's to be
installed information has to come into
the department before it is installed uh
and we would always check lighting with
environmental health to ensure that
there isn't you know light pollution to
either residential properties or indeed
you know in the in the wider area
although obviously we are in an urban
environment so it's not it's not
considered that there's a need for
looking at it for say ecology reasons or
anything like that so taking into
account the safeguarding conditions and
the changes to the proposal
the recommendation is for approval thank
you chair thank you ian i moved the
officer's recommendation uh could the
vice chair please second i'll prove that
uh
thank you councillor mccook um members
council crediton
[Music]
i always do that i'm sorry counselor
council hopkins and i do beg your pardon
have you feeling better by the way on
the sand
you've been
um yeah this one's actually in uh in my
wards and um
and scouts the moors as well
and there is there is a bit of
consternation amongst some of the
residents about this and um i i think
they're they're a good other
justify grounds some of their concerns
although i do think
their concerns are things that which
could be uh
mitigated or do you think there's a way
to kind of sell them but she'll come
back to a minute but they've got five
points i just want to mention these five
things really quickly
as
uh mr livingstone just mentioned there's
the light pollution issue but it's but
perhaps what you said mitigates that in
the sense that uh
i wasn't aware of anything residents are
aware that actually um
any any additional lighting would have
to be uh okay by the planning department
but you know the flood lights the
gardens tend to do at the moment cause
light pollution
and residents are concerned that that
could that could get worse
um noise pollution they are concerned
about so as we're just talking about um
this provides for uh
traffic to come in and out of the
warehouse from 7am five days a week
and so
residents have concerns that that's
that's not that wouldn't be you know it
would be very disruptive and not fair to
them and i think on the first version of
this it was uh eight a.m
and the the environment officer on the
report does say metal cladding
and this along with uh proposed doors
and roller shots have the potential to
cause a noise nuisance that is
acknowledged in the tdc officers um
report on this
um but the
officer does also say they're happy to
um
suggest the 7 a.m time is okay but they
don't i don't think the report explains
why
um but it does seem to me that's that's
a bit a bit much for the residents to
expect
there is some concern from residents on
mia road of the elevation overshadowing
properties that's the third point
fourth one it has been moved back from
perimeter but residents are still
concerned it's it's not far enough back
from the perimeter from the first one
and lastly fifth point um
uh it's it's about whether it's actually
meets some policy qd02 i think it is on
general design principles
ramsgate town council um uh don't feel
that it does
and there are a number of residents that
also don't feel that it does meet the
requirement of being in keeping with the
design of the area and the developer has
actually said they they are up they are
quite willing to meet with residents and
talk about concerns and actually i think
there is a way
forward through that to
kind of address all of these things
we weren't able to get it that meeting
done before they came here but they are
open to that and i really think it would
be uh
much more desirable if if residents
concerns were listened to and you know
you know if the application was amended
to take those into account so i don't
think it's there at the moment
personally and but i think there is a
way to get there
if we can set that meeting up which
myself and counselor moore
would
work on to make sure that residents
could meet the developer
uh thank you councillor hopkinson got it
right that did you want to come back on
any of those points in
yeah um thank you chair um to just come
back with regards to the question about
opening hours um this sort of followed
on from environmentals looking at the
scheme and and considering obviously
putting forward as you've seen from the
comment about potentially an 8 a.m start
um what we obviously then had to look at
was well
what what what governs the current use
of the site and from looking through the
planning history it's very clear that
there isn't anything that is restricting
the existing hours of use and especially
with regards to the current use of that
area um it's considered that we we
wouldn't be in a position to put
anything overly onerous on because at
the moment there is a sort of fallback
position which is that it can be used at
the moment
earlier than um well earlier than eight
and earlier than seven um but we do
recognize the fact that by putting a
warehouse there it has as i said it has
the potential to formalize it and so the
balance here is that it's the 7am start
which i appreciate maybe concerning to
to some residents but in comparison to
the existing situation it's considered
there is an additional harm created from
the restriction that we've proposed
thank you chad
uh thank you council heart
[Music]
thank you chair um my only comments to
this realistically is that one assumes
they're going to use a forklift and it's
going to be a curtain-sided lorry um
probably juggle they call it these days
i don't know what they call it um now if
the residents back onto that why not
where those green lines are have the
door there so that you can use curtain
side lorry can pull in against that and
you've got less movement of forklift to
unload that now that might
alter the way they use their warehouse
but at the end of the day the warehouse
is protecting the residents from the
noise of the forklift and the lorry and
the reversing of the lorry to a degree
because they make a hell of a dim and
they do it at seven o'clock or 6 30 in
the morning so
um from my idea i think the best
solution for that would be to have the
door on the side where the green lanes
work because that's more practical and
useful for laurie to turn up in that
area because i know the area i've been
to we've all been to the um all been to
that uh nursery um and my other coin is
i think is very early um if you're a
tree surgeon or a builder you're not
really supposed to start before 7 30.
um and i think that realistically 7 30
is a more reasonable time
than 7 o'clock that's my own personal
view but i do think that i think it
works out it needs to be turned around
to protect the residents from the noise
i think that could be a beneficial um
thing for the residents really
i think that's hard
um thanks so the two things i mean one
thing is obviously we considering the
proposal in front of us in terms of um
the specific use of the roll shutter
door if if obviously it's um you looking
effectively to relocate the entrance to
the north you obviously then you know
you you change the impact from being
potentially i suppose affecting more of
the property where the mouse pointer is
properties on muir road and you
potentially then open up to
i suppose an increased level of
disturbance to the properties on brindle
grove so you do
one way or another there will be an
impact there is the additional
uh fact that in this instance what the
the green lines that you mentioned are
trees
and so obviously if they had the
entrance there you would remove a line
which you can just about see again where
the mouse pointer is here
a line of sort of scrub growth and
smaller trees that do sort of delineate
the open storage area at the moment from
the car park of the garden center
again
the restriction with regards to time um
does restrict the use obviously of that
warehouse and you know to ensure that it
doesn't go earlier than seven and again
it it relates more to the extent use of
the site that we think that restriction
is is acceptable i take your point about
730 maybe even more appropriate um but
again given the fallback position here
which is
any time use and obviously
you know potentially with builders
materials or depending on what the
garden center is doing obviously you've
got you know shed construction all sorts
of stuff
it could be used from six at the moment
whether or not it is or not um you know
i can't say but i think this is the this
is the balanced approach with regards to
the opening hours that we've put on in
officer's view thank you chair thank you
ian uh councillor patmore
thank you chair uh
this is my ward
and i only live around the corner i was
in there today in the garden center i go
quite often and
i can't understand it where
the trees are you keep moving the
pictures
where the trees are
there's a big uh lorry behind it
and
and then
as you're coming in
over there and you come around where the
lorries are going to come and the
uh other bits
mechanics
there is the
uh car wash
i don't know how they can get through
might i propose we do a site visit and
then we can actually see
what's going on there
and although they have lowered
the height of it
it was ginormous in the first place
so you know i don't think they've given
a lot up by lowering it a bit but i
really think
uh
i couldn't get round i came down
towards the
car wash which is there and then the
lorry's there the trailer is there where
the trees are
and
i couldn't get around there to see
because the car wash is there and they
bring their cars in and out and park
them there in the way
so
you know i think
a site visit might help
i think that uh council more i'll come
to that if we have to council hopkinson
can want to come back
yeah thanks chair um
yeah just on on the noise issue again i
don't know if you know if there's any
good reason for this concern but some
residents are concerned
about you know a possible change of use
to
what the warehouse is for and concerned
that it might that might involve actual
more traffic flow in which case
you know then i think we would we really
then it'd be more
urgent sort of take take note at this
point um
but again that's something which could
be addressed
through you know perhaps residents
concerns could be
sort of
you know addressed on that by actually
meeting the developer um but i do think
agreeing with councillor moore that uh
you know site visit potentially is a way
for
for committee to judge the extent to
which these concerns are
are um you know are valid
uh
council hopkins um counts upon more
yes thank you chair first i'd like to
apologize to the green party because i
don't have a green garden mine's all
concrete and astroturf so i'm i don't
visit this this site very often um my
query is the current space we saw had
pallets on it and is that used by
forklifts or just by pallet loaders
and if so as an open space that would be
noisy in itself
and the fact that that's now possibly
being relocated into a structure is
going to absorb that noise so the only
noise pollution you're going to have is
actually unloading of the vehicles and
then into the structure itself
i'm glad to see they've reduced it in
size so i did think it was rather large
i'm glad to see that the planning
officers have agreed about light
pollution and much like upton school
obviously when not in use they can be
turned off and also they can have
security likes pyro which means they
only come on when ontruders or whatever
or people that shouldn't be there or
there for the security of the building
which they probably have to have for
their insurance purposes anyway
um
i've i do i'm aware i did read the
document where it said there was a car
washing and i think maybe that might
mean that a site visit would be prudent
just to tick the boxes and make sure
that how we perceive it unloading the
loading will be okay
i'm not too sure about councillor hearts
moving the doorway because we're meaning
we're removing that green area which i
think we should keep
and obviously if there's a condition
that is used purely for the garden
center then that mitigates any problems
for future years thank you
thank you councilman moore
uh
councilwing
oh yeah i'm also on rtc and we we
rejected this the first time we reject
it again the second time i think exactly
the same with upton school we've got a
neighbor issue here and we all want that
nursery to survive uh because we will
want to buy our plants with the
exception of
cancer more i'll bring you a potted
plant later
and we all want that that area to
generate employment but i do think there
are a number of residence issues and and
actually issues for both rtc and and me
as a ramsgate
town councillor as well that need to be
addressed and i think a site visit would
be would be prudent i mean looking at
that site now it just seems to be a
storage area rather than a storage area
obviously for pallets rather than a
storage area for goods and the
introduction of a warehouse to me does
tell me that there is going to be
increased activity of delivery of goods
which is a good thing because it means
that business is surviving but on the on
the flip side we do need to try and like
we did up like that that they did up to
school try and get the developer to
engage with the residents to try and
address some of these issues because i
feel absolutely certain that they can be
addressed in exactly the same way they
were with upton school
uh thank you council wing
uh council curry
yeah i also think it's um it's a good
idea to take advantage of the fact that
the developer is still willing to talk
to
the residents i think that's a good sign
maybe with the the start time maybe
could go back to half past seven
or push four to half seven so i think
that we should take advantage of that
thank you chair uh then council hurry
up
thank you
excuse me
what worries me is that if we're not
careful we will actually
go against the residents we will
increase their noise levels
the
at the moment
if they wished they could go in there at
six o'clock tomorrow morning with
forklift trucks moving those paddles all
over the place
that doesn't help residents surely
so
to me
i actually think that if the noise is
contained within a building i would have
thought that's better for residents
thank you chad
thank you
sir
thank you chair i entirely agree i i
think that the um
the formation of a warehouse would
contain the noise i understand that
residents don't like change but as far
as i can see
every effort has been made to
um to meet their requirements um
we'll have to look at what we're we're
the the application that's here before
us today and
i can only see benefits from it so i
should be supporting the application uh
thank you councilwoman
i just wondered if uh officers could
comment on the um issue raised about the
accessibility with regard to the um car
washing
[Music]
um obviously the i myself as an officer
haven't been on site the case officer
has been ourselves to take these images
um it's worth noting as well that the
location of where this warehouse is
obviously has access that's currently
used by the lorries etc that use it so
it's not considered that there is an
issue with regards to accessing the site
particularly because obviously again
it's in use at the moment and that
access therefore wouldn't necessarily
change but there's clearly going to be a
delineation between public access to the
car park and private access with regards
to any vehicles delivering bits and
pieces so just to go through the images
again so again this is the view to to
muir road at the moment
so that's the south of the site towards
brindle grove again you can see where
the general waste is currently kept so
we are effectively standing on where the
warehouse would be so you can see
clearly these are this is where all the
general waste is kept for the whole
garden center so again vehicles are
accessing this location so again there's
no issue in terms of conflict between
public and private
vehicle movements um and then this is
the the yard so we are sort of standing
with the warehouse location just behind
us
and so you can see again the open space
that's currently being used for vehicles
to come in from the right hand side of
the image um to access both the area to
the um in front of you that's gated off
with obviously more of the the plants
that are actually out there so that's
actually part of the garden centre
itself but you can see again
materials on the left-hand side again
which will be
you know related to the deliveries that
occur in that area so there isn't a
concern for us that there's a conflict
between where potentially the car wash
and when you're looking at this proposal
in comparison to obviously the current
the current arrangement basically
thank you thank you again
thank you chad i think people um
are getting a bit confused with the fact
of all warehouse um the point of a
warehouse or a bum is that it keeps
things dry um and therefore you can put
different materials in there and use
that as a facility to keep everything in
a better condition the downside to quite
often a lot of bonds and or shares and i
have been in quite a few believe it or
not um is that a noise can echo and
reverberate and make even more noise
than an outside space
um so if if the building is going up and
it's just tin
then it will make more noise with a
diesel forklift than it will with an
electric forklift
inside a
uh a building that is insulated and that
you have insulated foam cladding or
whatever they're going to use so it does
make a difference i mean you put 12 cows
in a bottom they make more noise and 12
cows outside and and that's just what
happens and you put a machine going down
a forklift going down a long bar it will
reverberate and reverberate and
reverberate so it does depend on how
they're going to use it and what they're
going to use it what machinery they're
going to use inside
um and i think that has to be
appreciated by everybody because you
know a diesel fortnite makes a row
it does make a round think of that
counts the heart do i understand but i'm
coming past the number two again
um yeah just to come back on that again
that i'd take your point council heart
the balance here is the time condition
so that is the how we're trying to
address you know again what could be
that formalization of use it could
potentially again we we wouldn't we
wouldn't impose additional controls in
terms of
types of equipment used because again
there's a free use related to the
current planning unit of what they could
use that area for at the moment in terms
of the different equipment etcetera but
the time condition is is the mitigation
to avoid there being a significant
impact on neighbouring properties taking
a more your point about 730 rather than
7 but again following the um looking at
the history and speaking to
environmental health the the balance
here in our view is is the seven o'clock
start
thank you chad thank you anne
uh councillor
king
thank you um i mean i'd like to have a
site visit i think sufficient concerns
have been raised here tonight that i
don't feel have been fully answered i
would also like to know what time you
know i know you say there are no time
restrictions on it but what time
currently the garden center is having
people working in that area
[Music]
no
i think the answer there at the moment
we're not sure
um
counselor more
thank you chairman could i just mention
living so close
to this uh garden center and i use it
quite a lot
uh
that
i have i've seen cars outside of lorries
at eight o'clock in the morning waiting
to get in it's locked up i think it's
half past eight when they open
so it's going to be
a bit of a
a shock
from 8 30 in the morning to opening at
7.
i think you've just confused everything
there councilman
really
uh counselor wing
no
i think what what a councillor was
trying to say that presently no
deliveries arrived after
the the the
the garden center opens
so
there might i for me having listened to
everybody discussing there are so many
unknowns here so if there are no
deliveries and that's what councilman
moore is suggesting there are no
deliveries because they're sat outside
waiting for the whole place to open at
half eight then giving them
seven is going to have a reverse impact
on the residents
what are they actually going to do it's
a warehouse are they using it to store
are they using it to move equipment in i
think a site visit and i definitely
believe that council hopkinson's trying
to get the resident's concerns uh laid
by talking to the developer and the
nursery to find out exactly what they're
using it for when do they want to use it
would help delay some of the fears of
close neighbors we've got exactly the
same situation as a sports hall in upton
in upton school and i think the best way
forward would be for a site visit and
for the developer to win
a meeting to be engineered so that
residents can talk to the developer and
their their view their concerns can be
aired
uh thank you for that uh
councillor wing
council
yes thank you sir um do we know what the
um products are for the um warehouse
whether it's sandwich panels insulation
etc because obviously that will impact
if it's sandwich panels it should absorb
um
i didn't see it so i thought i'd ask
here
um i don't have that information i can
check the application form potentially
but i believe that the information only
extends to effectively a warehouse and
again the use is not proposed to change
so again what they could store in the
warehouse could vary um
so would you make it a condition that it
would be insulation in that structure
so again the the proposal as it's been
put forward we've we've considered that
to be acceptable related to
environmental health comment about again
existing use and what they're proposing
so um whether or not it's necessary and
that's the key test in terms of a
condition to alleviate a harm
we obviously haven't put that forward um
because we don't think there's
sufficient evidence given the extent use
of the site
thank you
thank you
thank you thank you and um
and i think
members are aware that i am
allowed to speak to the officers and i
think with advice as well
um
devices members uh
i am quite happy to withdraw my proposal
um which i gave you earlier which was
rightly seconded by councillor coleman
cook
and put forward and ask for
a proposal for
a site visit obviously there's a lot of
um feeding on this
and obviously there's a lot of unknowns
which is no no fault over the offices at
all
um
i know the site um
i know what it used to be and i think a
few other people might remember what it
used to be but that's different story
but um
hare's running around with greyhounds
behind them um
but
so
if um i'd like a proposal for a site
visit which you may recall i said would
be on friday the 1st of october
proposal please
counts
yes yes sorry sorry
must do it correctly
i've agreed as chair to withdraw the
proposal i must have a second i wish i
will come back to council coleman cook
who was seconded i'll certainly yeah
thank you council court i'll do it
properly otherwise i get told off
um
thank you and your members you agree
they're withdrawn okay
so can i just um ask uh the proposal
you're about to make um about a site
visit can it also include that uh the
questions that we've raised here tonight
uh are also addressed i don't know if
you were in going to include that or not
with a site visit we haven't had one for
i don't know how long which is going to
be a day
i probably can't make
what i would do obviously i speak to
the planning officer
because with site visits if my memory
serves me right there are only certain
things
i can ask
and also members can ask
at a site visit
but by that time which is october
a couple of weeks down the line
hopefully um
counselor
i don't know why i really
hopkins i've done it before so i gotta
apologize to you
put it in big enough letters down here
um but perhaps by then you will have
gathered
a little bit more information which
would be useful at a site visit but the
rules for a site visit for members who
haven't been on them
they are again very strict
and
you know you don't we don't decide
anything on a site visit because it will
come back to yourselves as members of a
committee
okay
so right
sorry
normally about uh 9 30
not 9 30 on
a.m
it's um it won't be six o'clock in the
morning
okay
so
councilman
sorry chet uh having never been to a
site visit um does every member of the
planning committee have to attend that
if
or if you can't make it do you have to
if um as in the past so it's a long time
ago now but um
please as many members
but please don't worry about substitutes
um you don't have to do that people do
people do work
[Music]
um just to confirm the the reason why uh
what we'd like to do is
try and see if we can get any additional
information um before the site visit but
what we would always look to do is
report back the following month when it
comes back after the site visit because
obviously members can't attend and so
the issue with the cybers is for those
members that are there to simply see um
if there are questions that come up on
the site visit we will try and answer
them as officers with regards to the
submission
but it's about not having a debate
because fundamentally not all the
members of the committee are there
so that's why the debate then saves for
for when it comes back to committee
thank you
thank you
uh
right i need a proposal for the site
visit please
counselor hopkinson i got it right that
time
seconded by
council pat moore